[Music]
as the bells chimed for 11 o'clock
everywhere you look there were members
of the royal family with the queen
resting at home her relatives turning
out in force for the service of
thanksgiving at some pools
but inevitably two were always going to
stand out
harry keen to make sure megan was okay
gesturing to her to check the collar of
her dress
before they walked up the steps the
reaction from the crowd seemed to be
mixed
[Applause]
i have my own opinions but i wouldn't
have booze because you know it's a happy
occasion it's a happy occasion to
celebrate the 17th year not to
boo the um people yeah a couple of dudes
but oh not from this side not on this
side we all gave them a cheer i think
you will always get you know one or two
dissenters you know but we were fine
we're very happy with it yeah
they took their seats next to his
cousins and their spouses
as the welcome sounded for his father
the prince of wales greeting his other
son and daughter-in-law as he stepped in
to represent the
queen but the image of him walking with
prince william was a signal of how
they're jointly taking on the
responsibilities of the monarch
keep on doing the things
that you have learned and received
and heard
and seen in me
with lighter reminders of how she
remains in charge
we all know
that the queen likes horse racing and
your majesty
i'm rather assuming perhaps you're
watching this on the television and i'm
afraid i don't have any great tips for
the derby tomorrow
her influence there in the music and the
congregation the queen wanting to invite
others who've served their communities
and been rewarded for it
so you just felt her spirit and energy
in the room and of course when we were
praying
you know it was only right that we held
her
in our prayers just wishing her well
throughout it all harry and megan were
sitting in the opposite aisle at a
distance from his father and brother a
contrast to the last big event where
they joined the royal family
that event was the commonwealth day
service in march 2020 and it was a
complete field date for body language
experts nobody wanted to see a repeat of
that not least the queen who was no
doubt watching her family very closely
back at home
for her they remain much-loved members
of the family but as the others attended
a reception at the guild hall the
sussexes were already making their own
way home
[Music]
[Applause]
rhiannon mills sky news at st paul's
cafe